on est tous déguisés en avait 88 ans tom
cruise ouais là ça se voit top gun ah
ouais ouais ouais un plâtre ça se voit
et mais cette fois bien je touchais bien
subtile pour une fois je me suis pas
entraîné on dirait un mélange de top gun
et de mon cousin dû s'en tenir aux des
noms mais si ses frères dis moi tu les
tue la suit dans 46 villes américaines
merci non mais alors ça va vous êtes
très beau match mais on est tous en
années 80 on va accueillir tout de suite
le premier c'est jean michel maire à
votre avis en quoi il est c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces droits c'est ma sai indochine ou cdi
prière pourquoi on est tous en année cas
comme aujourd'hui je me suis je demande
à celui qui a le plus beau c'est cette
question alors parce qu'on reçoit
patrick sabatier qui est une des stars
des années 80 alors on va cueillir à
bout de trouver aussi en quoi ils sont
agiles et isabelle c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît alors on vous a reconnu
on sait que c'est valérie benaïm vous
asseyez et enora tu vas t'asseoir vous
êtes magnifique l'air bien
ah ouais franchement c'est top c'est y à
fond dans le rôle à la fin de l'émission
prenait une douche
ah oui mais on va pas faire la merci de
faire allez on va cueillir maintenant
alors je vous le dis elle est un petit
avantage c'est qu'elle avait déjà la
moustache
à votre avis on doit regarder
[Musique]
voilà
allez papa j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit
ça mais je ne pensais pas que c'était
bouquet le deuxième est bon sens mais
pas du tout un beau lob mais je sais que
chaque amoureux des livres on va vous
étiez un drôle de voyage mais sans
rigoler on dirait du pont du préfet
juste demandé pourquoi à chaque fois
homo mais avec un mec qui a une
moustache on m'a fait faire astérix avec
la moustache me posez vous les bonnes je
vous hais cette vanne de valérie benaïm
dabou stage sachez que c'est une légende
parce que ça n'est pas une tâche à
l'adulte un petit peu du pays ni est
atterré par laquelle je m'étais parce
qu'elle ressemble à crous castillo dans
santa barbara s'avérer un écart final
alors oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour accueillir maintenant raymond a
votre avis il est en quoi raymond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bois de boulogne première façon tu
peux pas t'en vas t'on à gauche on va
s'occuper tôt c'est bon d'être là allez
on passe à aa à aa
face à francesca à votre avis pourquoi
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais elle continue dans le seul secteur
où la tombe
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est toujours réticentes pour se
déguiser mais toujours ouverte pour
rigoler c'est christine partie
[Applaudissements]
rien juste une bonne attitude sur la
quatrième de retirer on dirait philippe
noiret dans l'est mais pour la première
fois deux voies couleur menthe à l'eau
et des biens dans la loupe
on est devant sur couleur menthe à l'eau
dans la 6ème laval a souvent vignola
jones --une il manque le sabre ça fou
est nommé regarde regarde il regarde
c'est quoi ça sert vous avez l'air très
intéressant vraiment mais vraiment je le
dis vraiment comme je le porte
à paris on va passer maintenant
vous avez envie d'avoir de voir
quelqu'un de sexy oui allez celui-là on
a envie d'en voir une très sexy c'est
pour vous dire je suis comme un fou
depuis tout à l'heure je la vois c'est
un truc de ouf je fais georges la
regarde pas mais je suis comme un ouf
sur elle daniel moreau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
roberto d'asie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi et par renault et la famille
fatale à elle a le bruit quand tu pas à
la famille cinq brésiliens mon père est
gentil aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 30 ans attaquant il
racontant ses rides
oui profite que je suis en renault pour
demander s'il y avait un volontaire qui
voudrait me faire le plein est atteint
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va terminer avec bien sûr celles qui
m'ont si ça avait travaillé dans quoi
sabrina comme la régie c'est aller dans
sa bride à ses côtés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette annonce d'une piscine normal je
préviens et on dirait pas en dire est
une boutique en fait c'est rigolo mais
oui c'est du sondage va vous laisser de
vous laisser on m'offre un ver du sol à
tout va si vous dites les gars qui
faisait sourire mais c'est vrai mais ça
vient ça lui va bien mais vous vous
ressemblez demi cobas